[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi à 20 juin tout de suite les
titres de cette édition est la majorité
municipale se déchire à coignières le
maire jean-pierre sevestre a saisi le
procureur de la république pour des
manquements en très grave dans le viseur
son deuxième adjoint ali bousselham qui
s'est vu retirer ses délégations
résultat un début de conseil municipal
sous tension et hier et jean-pierre
semestre et notre invité pour en parler
elle est sauvée longtemps en péril la
villa viardot à bougival va pouvoir être
restaurer le monument yvelinois été
sélectionnés parmi 18 6 pour bénéficier
du loto du patrimoine une initiative
lancée par le journaliste stéphane bern
reportage sur place
et puis en ce jour de sortie au cinéma
elle revient à l'écran bécassine et
l'héroïne du dernier film de denis
podalydès alibi noir était de retour
dans sa ville versailles pour présenter
le film en avant première et c'est un
film non pas de denis podalydès mais
deux bruno podalydes à son frère à nous
recevrons également tout à l'heure un
autre invité pierre vézy qu'est le
président de la spa yvelines association
pour le développement des soins
palliatifs
elle organise ce samedi une rencontre
sur le sujet également sur
l'accompagnement et des bénévoles
on accueille tout de suite sur ce
plateau jean pierre sevestre bonsoir
bonsoir avec le maire sans étiquette et
de coignières alors avant de parler de
votre action en justice et des tensions
actuelles au sein de votre conseil
municipal elle vous êtes tout juste de
retour aux affaires dans votre mairie
après un mois d'absence pour raisons de
santé
est ce que vous allez mieux aujourd'hui
ça va mieux mais je dois subir une
intervention prochainement 10 3 semaines
des interventions chirurgicales pour me
permettre de retrouver une mobilité est
meilleur alors pendant votre absence
une décision importante a été prise au
sein de la mairie l'abandon du projet de
communes nouvelles avec maurepas face à
l'opposition des habitants 200 habitants
de
de coignières s'étaient réunis devant la
mairie début mais c'est un dossier qui
vous tenait à coeur comment vous avez
vécu l'abandon ce projet à distance
c'est vrai c'est à distance que j'ai
vécu sept abandons de projets c'est un
projet qui dans un premier temps devait
lancer les études de fusion et de
création de communes nouvelles avec
maurepas c'était une première étape à
nous avons voulu être transparents
effectivement et avant de faire les
études nous avons voulu effectivement en
conseil municipal d débattre des études
qui devait être fait pour trouver les
impacts qu'ils pouvaient être pour les
mortuaciens et pour les coigné rien mais
je l' ai vécu d'une façon un peu bien
sûr j'étais déçu de l'abandon de ce
projet mais je considère que si les
poignées rien effectivement ont donné un
avis plutôt négatif même pour lancer les
études ce que je regrette je me plie
bien sûr à la vie de la population la
pression avant de voir le premier sujet
vos soucis de santé vous ont également
poussé à démissionner de votre poste de
vice président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines aux sports à
quelques mois seulement du début de la
ryder cup la décision était est
inévitable la décision était inévitable
pour moi mais avec beaucoup de regrets
avec beaucoup de regrets c'est un poste
tellement passionnant tellement
intéressant et le sport c'est un c'est
une c'est une activité qui me qui me
passionne mais j'ai été obligé
effectivement pour des raisons de santé
d'abandonner la vice présidence avec
beaucoup de regret je le répète j'en
parlais tout à l'heure des tensions hier
lors du conseil municipal de coignières
ont raison d'une forte affluence de la
population et d'une salle trop petite
celui ci a dû être ajourné un conseil
qui a débuté sur fond de polémique
puisque le deuxième adjoint en charge de
la culture ali bouziane s'est vu retirer
sa délégation ambiance avec aurélie rose
début de conseil municipal mouvementé à
coignières il ya quelques jours le maire
jean-pierre sevestre a saisi le
procureur de la république pour des
irrégularités et des manquements
réglementaire très grave au sein de son
équipe depuis trois ans je suis attelé
à remettre je dirais d'aplomb un petit
peu juridiquement et réglementairement
la maison car nous avions effectivement
une gestion auparavant qu'ils
négligeaient parfois la réglementation
en ligne de mire le précédent maire de
la ville henri bayeux et l'instituteur
et adjoint en charge de la culture ali
bousselham une délégation qui vient de
lui être retiré par arrêté jean-pierre
sevestre lui reprochent notamment
d'occuper un logement de 140 mètres
carrés sans payer de loyer depuis six
ans une situation que l'adjoint se
refuserait à régulariser loyer pour un
logement fonction d'instituteur
j'estime que c'est à juste de me
déshonorer pour quelque chose qui est
qui et pas juste qui n'est pas en tout
cas qui n'est pas les qui n'est pas
légal quoi un homme d'honneur je
proposerai à ce que mes se baissent de
retirer cela s'il le retire écoutez
je me ravise ray je n'irai pas ester en
justice parce que voilà c'est ça qui est
gênant pour des raisons de sécurité
l'assemblée vote le report du conseil et
une date ultérieure dans un lieu plus
grand conseil municipal à journée donc
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on sait la date du
prochain
ça nous avons pas encore la date et le
lieu du prochain conseil municipal du
report du prochain conseil municipal
salle plus grande en tout cas une salle
plus grande qui pourrait accueillir une
affluence un peu plus importante rui
alors vous l'avez entendu ali ben
mussalam le dit dans le reportage ils se
sont déshonorés estime être dans son bon
droit être instituteur la loi le dit il
a le droit il a été instituteur et a le
droit aujourd'hui d'avoir un logement de
fonction qui est fourni par la commune
sans payer loyer du coup et où est ce
que oui le problème pardon pour vous
est-ce que ça pose problème
oui ça pose problème effectivement c'est
un problème de moralisation un peu de la
vie politique
un instituteur a le droit effectivement
d'être le g par la commune il a le droit
d'être logés par la commune ou de
percevoir une indemnité mensuelle de 234
euros environ pour se loger autrement
que par la municipalité
actuellement nous avons monsieur ali
bousselham qui est logé dans un pavillon
de 140 m² et 6 pour la moralisation de
la vie politique je pense que nous avons
également une institutrice qui est logé
dans un appartement à coignières de 75
m² environ
et je considère que d'être logés pour
monsieur ali bousselham dans un pavillon
du double avec jardin je considère que
c'est la taille qui pose problème
effectivement puisque les décrets
prévoient effectivement une taille
minimum et un logement convenable de 60
plus de 70 m² pour une famille de quatre
personnes
un décret qui date des années 80 vous
avez donc retiré c'est d'égal délégation
pardon à monsieur bousselham qui reste
tout de même encore 2e adjoint encore
aujourd'hui il était l'un des membres de
votre majorité qui s'affichait contre le
projet de rapprochement avec one year
n'y at-il pas à 100 tout cas le
sentiment qu'il a en s'entretenant avec
lui hier n'y at il pas une part de
vengeance aussi dans cette décision vous
avez prises non
nullement nullement de vengeance dans ce
dans cette affaire le logement
effectivement c'est une affaire avec
laquelle je parle avec monsieur
bousselham depuis de nombreux mois
je lui ai demandé au mois d'octobre et
on va décembre 2010 est de régulariser
cette situation qui me paraît tout de
même un passe droit
un élu de la république qui
effectivement profite de la propriété de
la commune pour être logés de cette
façon donc je considère qu'il doit
régulariser la situation
et depuis cette date là monsieur
bousselham n'a aucunement données
l'intention de régulariser la situation
et je pense qu'actuellement même
l'interview avait fait hier il n'a pas
l'intention effectivement de régulariser
cette situation alors dans votre action
en justice jean-pierre sevez vous
dénoncez également des manquements
réglementaire très grave dont certains
relèvent du délit notamment un refus
passé de mise en concurrence des
fournisseurs pour les marchés publics et
les grands travaux de la ville je vous
cite c'est là est clairement visé
l'ancien maire de la ville henri
pailleux votre prédécesseur qui vous a
key à par don qui a démissionné en 2015
henri payet était également farouchement
opposé au projet de communes nouvelles
on fera réagir on n'a pas pu
l'interroger on le fera réagir sans
tarder l'objectif de notre action c'est
quoi du coup c'est d'identifier les
responsabilités de chacun tout à fait
c'est d'identifier les responsabilités
de chacun je pense que là l'ensemble de
la majorité depuis deux ans depuis deux
ans régularise régularise les actions
passées et qui n'ont pas été faites dans
l'est dans les formes réglementaires et
à partir du moment où il y à des
personnes effectivement comme monsieur
bousselham qui ne
ne veulent pas effectivement régulariser
des affaires telles que celles que nous
avons exposé je considère qu'il faut
mettre les personnes devant leurs
responsabilités et c'est la justice
ensuite qui jugera du coup jean pierre
serait-ce quid de votre majorité au sein
du conseil municipal écoutez à ce propos
ali bousselham c'est une majorité qui ne
porte deux noms qui n'a de majorité que
de nom parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
à peu près 8 à coignières avenir qui est
donc notre groupe au départ ce devait
être une sensibilité au sein d'une
majorité plurielle mais très vite très
vite j'ai été donc attaquer mais à mes
amis du même groupe de cette majorité
larmes dit non on est déjà considéré
comme des opposants
donc de fait par conséquence en fait
la partie moment on attaque une personne
qui est dans votre groupe qui n'a pas la
même sensibilité d'une manière je dois
le dire d'une élégante
vous la mettez de fait d'une manière
implicite dans l'opposition donc je suis
opposé effectivement aujourd'hui au
reliquat de la majorité cogneur
démocratie pour les raisons de cette
tentative de me déshonorer jean-pierre
sevestre votre majorité au sein du
conseil municipal et de dix sept membres
d'après monsieur bousselham ils sont
huit maintenant au sein de ce groupe à
être désormais opposant es ce que vous
avez toujours aujourd'hui une majorité
au sein de ce qu'on est bien c'est à
dire actuellement il y à des tensions
effectivement au sein de notre majorité
il nous faut passer au-dessus au su de
c2c affaire je dirais nous avons conclu
ce projet de création de communes
nouvelles c'est une affaire passée nous
l'avons abandonné totalement
donc il nous faut maintenant reprendre
les projets que nous avons envisagé pour
il nous faut maintenant repartir sur des
bases solides au sein d'une majorité et
il nous faut pour cela que tout le monde
se mette autour de la table et qu'on
puisse effectivement repartir d'un bon
pas aller de l'avant ça sera ça sera ma
dernière question du coût aussi il ya
des élus huit élus par le monsieur
bousselham dont parle monsieur
bousselham ça va être difficile de vous
maintenir dans ces conditions et bien
écoutez les je ne pense que je me
maintiens dans ces conditions et j'ai la
ferme intention effectivement de
maintenir une majorité à coignières et
je n'ai pas l'intention pour l'instant
de passer la main effectivement je suis
un maire actuellement qui aura osé à
coignières assainir la gestion et ça
j'en suis assez fier oui votre premier
objectif arriver là c'était plus un
objectif lorsque je suis arrivé mais
compte tenu de la situation que j'ai
trouvé j'ai osé assainir la situation je
suis en train d'assainir la situation et
j'en suis assez fier et on suivra la
suite de ces actualités à coignières et
notamment le conseil municipal qui
devrait arriver dans les prochains jours
merci jean pierre sauvestre d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire sans étiquette de coignières merci
bonsoir
un rendez vous dédié à la création et à
la reprise d'entreprise hier à l'estac à
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des yvelines a organisé son business
evening avocats experts comptables
organismes de financement étaient réunis
pour rencontrer et conseiller les
créateurs d'entreprise est les porteurs
de projets ont pu participer à des
ateliers chaque année ce sont 700 à être
accompagné par la cci versailles
yvelines des propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est un rêve d'entreprendre et
on sait à peu près à quoi sert quels
organismes et on n'est pas sûr d'aller
le voir au bon moment où justement
l'idée d'organiser le business et ming
mais nous on est là pour ça pour essayer
de fluidifier au maximum une entreprise
qui se fait accompagner des la
structuration du projet a beaucoup plus
de chance
de survivre à trois un nouvel invité
avec moi emplettes où ces pierres bézy
montfort bon ça vous êtes le président
de la spa yvelines c'est l'association
pour le développement des soins
palliatifs alors vous organisé samedi au
café jus la saint germain en laye le
soin palliatif hour c'est une rencontre
sur les soins palliatifs et
l'accompagnement on va en parler
dans cet entretien est déjà pour poser
les bases de ce sujet n'est soins
palliatifs s'adresse aux malades en
phase critique ou en fin de vie quels
objectifs visent ses soins palliatifs il
s'agit d'apporter aux malades de le
soulagement delà de la douleur ça c'est
l'aspect médical ce sont les équipes
soignantes mais il s'agit aussi
d'assurer aux malades
le l'apaisement de la souffrance
psychologique psychique un étang à ses
côtés et a de la même façon aux côtés
des membres de la famille vous êtes le
président de l'ajs been quelle mission à
dans cette thématique justement des
soins palliatifs
une telle association c'est ça la
mission c'est à dire c'est
l'accompagnement des malades parce que
on est aux côtés des équipes soignantes
pour assurer un contact psychologique et
surtout un contact civile nous sommes
des personnes de la société civile qui
vont rencontrer d'autres personnes qui
ont été victimes de la maladie pour leur
redonner leur honneur dignité et leur
rôle de sujets en acceptant ou en
refusant une rencontre qu'on leur
propose un mot peut-être historique ça
fait longtemps que l'aspirine agit sur
le territoire la sp yvelines a été créée
en l'an 2000 2000 donc ça fait 18 ans on
est maintenant cinquante bénévoles
actifs une centaine d'adhérents dans dix
équipes qui disposent équipes qui
interviennent sur les établissements
hospitaliers de la région et on a de
grosses équipes qui travaillent au
domicile du rôle d'accompagnement est ce
que la mission aussi d'une telle
association c'est promouvoir finalement
les soins palliatifs auprès du grand
public et aussi auprès des
professionnels de santé
alors oui tout à fait on a on a un rôle
la deuxième partie de la mission de
notre association c'est aussi d'être
vecteur de pour répandre cette culture
palliative dont on parle pour ans pour
qu'enfin les soins palliatifs sorte de
cette de cette espèce de ghetto dans
lequel ils sont facilement enfermé qu'on
se rende compte que les soins palliatifs
ça peut concerner tout le monde ça peu
et ça ne concerne que des vivants qui
mérite d'être rencontrés comme des
personnes vivantes qui qui ont droit à
être restaurée dans leur statut de sujet
vous l'avez dit vous vous intervenez
auprès de plusieurs établissements
hospitaliers c'est ça sur le noir des
yvelines
oui on intervient notamment dans les si
je dois parler par région par ville
autour de saint germain pour marly
versailles le chesnay plaisir et autant
qu'on a on est dedans trois réseaux de
soins à domicile et on va bientôt être à
guyancourt et attrapes et à
maisons-laffitte je mérite war de saint
quentin en yvelines pour lui en cours et
trappes notamment
interventions dans des
établissements de santé ce qu'il ya
aussi des interventions à domicile
également qui sont faites par par votre
association
oui mais on travaille on a de grosses
équipes qui travaillent à domicile dont
la mission est la même que le
l'accompagnement et a le même but la
même fonction que dans des
établissements hospitaliers
sauf que c'est à domicile et c'est un
lien avec des équipes d'hospitalisation
domicile de médicale on l'a dit vous
organisé ce samedi une rencontre sur le
sujet des soins palliatifs également sur
l'accompagnement des bénévoles ça se
passe au café jules à
saint-germain-en-laye quels sont les
objectifs de cet événement alors cet
événement c'est une grande première
c'est une grande première puis on s'est
dit parce que fait jusqu'à maintenant on
ne communiquait pas peut-être pas
suffisamment du coup on a du mal à
recruter des bénévoles et pourtant il
nous en faudrait de plus en plus donc on
s'est dit eh bien parlons des soins
palliatifs parlons dans un endroit qui
respire la vie puisque c'est un café à
la mode du sang du centre de saint germé
en les fréquentait beaucoup par par les
jeunes au fait ça sous forme d'un espèce
de happy hours donc tout est gratuit
venez nombreux et on offre le le petit
déjeuner on s'est ouverte 10 heures à
midi on reçoit qui vient qui veut
pour communiquer sur le sujet c'est
important breux communiquer sur les
soins palliatifs on veut communiquer sur
l'accompagnement dans notre mission et
on veut essayer de susciter l'intérêt et
l'adhésion de nouveaux de nouveaux
participants a priori sur la forme ça
sera une rencontre quelque chose de
convivial qu'on puisse échanger assez
facilement sur sur le sujet voilà oui
nous serons plusieurs plus plusieurs
bénévoles donc de l'association pour
être capable de discuter avec avec les
les gens qui viendront nous rejoindre
on prend notre temps on passe une partie
de la matinée
on vient à 10 heures on vient à 11h en
cinquième quand on veut on reste le
temps qu'on veut quand on veut et ce
qu'il faut s'inscrire au préalable pas
besoin il va pas besoin de toute façon
les portes sont ouvertes
ce serait mieux que pour l'organisation
qu'on le sache donc sur notre page
facebook ou bien sur notre site
et ce pays vit s'affiche actuellement
d'ailleurs en bas de l'écran il rappelle
que cette rencontre est donc au
programme ce samedi au café jus la saint
germain en laye soins palliatifs hours
c'est de 10h à 12h merci pierre bézy
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
asp yvelines plus d'informations sur
l'association et et aussi sur la
thématique des soins palliatifs sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
plus de 100 collégiens yvelinois
récompensé hier mardi à la préfecture
des yvelines les élèves ont été décorés
dont le cadre du concours départemental
de la résistance et de la déportation
un prix qui a pour objectif d'entretenir
le devoir de mémoire chez les plus
jeunes et d'approfondir aussi leurs
connaissances en histoire est la
cérémonie s'est déroulée en présence
notamment de jacqueline fleury
résistante et déportée et de
l'inspecteur d'académie
d
line interview collectées par nicolas
kirillovitch quand on écoute le discours
de certains d'entre eux prononcés alors
qu'ils sont lauréats on s'aperçoit
qu'ils sont déjà plus que des historiens
en herbe qu'ils ont fait preuve d'une
maturité extraordinaire et qu'ils
portent en eux cette reconnaissance
fondamental de ceux qui ce sont deux
engagés comme j'ai pu le dire au péril
de leur vie pour que les valeurs de la
france et notre liberté triomphent d'une
période sombre et qui je l'espère et est
une période loin derrière nous là c'est
la maison symbole d'une histoire d'amour
poétique celle qui lie l écrivain ivan
tourguéniev et la cantatrice pauline
viardot un patrimoine aujourd'hui en
péril qui sera restaurée grâce au loto
du patrimoine la demeure de bougival
fait partie à des 18 monument
sélectionnés par stéphane bern
reportage de mélanie poké de la chambre
de pauline viardot il ne reste plus rien
des salons où était donné concert et bal
il ne reste que quelques peintures la
ville 1 est aujourd'hui en péril laissé
à l'abandon
en 2000 je lui retrouvé pour la première
fois donc cette maison qui qui
représente tellement pour un musicien et
donc je suis rentré dans ses salons les
j'ai eu mal au coeur j'ai pleuré pour
tout vous dire comment était ce possible
d'abandonner un haut lieu de la musique
le domaine est acheté en 1874 par la
cantatrice son mari et le romancier ivan
tourguéniev un lieu de foisonnement
intellectuel dont ces salons et c'est ça
qui est absolument magnifique
nous avons eu tous les grands esprits du
19e siècle de l'oural à l'atlantique
il y avait des russes il y avait des
néerlandais il y avait des belges il y
avait des italiens des anglais giles
deacon a probablement écrit certains
passages du david copperfield ici qui
ont fait de cette maison un haut lieu de
dialogue un haut lieu d'une conscience
européenne qui se dessinait de juin
à cette époque là des travaux dont le
montant s'élève à près de 3 millions
d'euros le site a été retenu par le loto
du patrimoine dont le premier tirage se
fera le 14 septembre prochain
non seulement c'est la reconnaissance de
ce que cette villa représente 3 millions
d'euros c'est une énorme somme notamment
pour une ville comme bougival qui est
une petite ville de 8000 900 habitants
et donc il est absolument essentiel que
l'état que les institutionnels
s'emparent de ce sujet et permettent la
rénovation de la villa une fois rénové
la villa intégrera un projet touristique
et artistique un grand centre de musique
etc la maison bizet composa son opéra le
plus célèbre carmen
elle n'est peut-être pas votre cousine
mais a sûrement rythmer votre enfance
bécassine débarque au cinéma aujourd'hui
mercredi la jeune fille naïve et
maladroite et l'héroïne du dernier film
du versailles et bruno podalydès le
réalisateur était de retour dans sa
ville natale
ce week-end pour présenter ce film
mélanie poquet et nicolas landry une
robe verte et une coiffe blanche
reconnaissable
revoilà bécassine la bigoudène est
remise au goût du jour le versailles et
bruno podalydès créé sa nounou 2018 tout
journal yves et empoté ceni c'est drôle
la seconde relie démunis des drôlesses
que bécassine elle est là quelque chose
de
je n'occulte ajustements
on lui reproche beaucoup de choses à 7
des cas side alors que c'est une jeune
femme de papier très attachante j'ai
appris à la découvrir en écrivant de
films et jeux
la fois drôle et émouvante c'est un bon
cocktail web au sein des castings
bonjour madeleine jour mademoiselle sa
tête on a vu passer trois nourrissons un
mois alors attention mademoiselle b
katrina c'est l'heure du biberon si tôt
mais le réalisateur du mystère de la
chambre jaune et le parfum de la dame en
noir signe ici son huitième long métrage
où il mélange gags originaux et nouvelle
invention avec au casting karin viard
denis podalydès
emeline bayart j'avais vu que cette
actrice était extraordinaire et méconnus
comme un peu comme bécassine et du coup
j'ai
en superposant les visages des mines et
dessins de bécassine j'ai vu un film
possible
j'ai écrit en pensant à elle le film a
suscité la colère d'un mouvement
indépendantiste breton mais cette
deuxième adaptation est à découvrir dans
les salles dès ce mercredi 20 juin c'est
urgent je reviens monsieur reste à
claques hausse à damien d'ortiz sa
coulpe l'appareil et sur tv 78 une
émission vais y paie d'ailleurs en ce
moment consacré à bruno podalydès allait
présenter cette émission par véronique
ithurbide avant de se quitter demain
c'est le début de l'été et traditionnel
jour de fête de la musique aussi à
beaucoup d'animations à saint quentin en
yvelines et ses alentours à plaisir par
exemple les classes du conservatoire
seront à écouter comme tout comme du
jazz manouche de la folk rock et du
blues rock
le rendez vous est fixé à 18 heures dans
le parc de l'hôtel de ville un magny les
hameaux attendra elle le week-end pour
les festivités concert à partir de 16h
samedi à la maison de l'environnement
demain jeudi sur le parvis du med à
montigny le bretonneux la soirée débute
à 19h des tubes au programme mais aussi
de la musique bretonne et une longue
balle géante enfin comme à magny les
hameaux et guyancourt organise sa fête
de la musique samedi des concerts à
retrouver notamment à la batterie qui a
proposera pour la soirée
cinq espaces scéniques c'est dès 18
heures voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal les reportages sont à revoir sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]